[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein super einfaches und
wirklich sehr leckeres erfrischendes
rezept ich habe einen kombinationen
gemacht aus kokos und erdbeeren jetzt
steht die erdbeerzeit bevor und ich
glaube diese komödie gefällt euch auch
ganz gut ich habe nämlich einen coconut
strawberry gemacht war also in einer tat
vor meine tat gebacken und das ganze hab
ich mit einem feinen mürbeteig gemacht
habe darüber eine creme gemacht es wird
kein cheesecake weil ich einfach kein
frisch käse und keinen quark ab sondern
eher mit kokosmilch und mit gesüßter
kondensmilch gearbeitet habe das ganze
ist wirklich super einfach das einzige
was wir beachten müsst ihr braucht eben
eine längere zeit weil der kuchen
einfach nach dem backen wirklich in den
kühlschrank muss da wieder schön
schnittfest wird ich finde es einfach
eine tolle alternative zur cheesecake
und die zutaten sind auch richtig
einfach und macht sie auch meistens
immer zu hause und wenn ihr keine
frischen erdbeeren habt oder noch keine
saison ist dann könnt ihr auch
aufgefordert zurückgreifen so habe ich
zumindest in erfüllung auch gemacht
ich starte zuerst einmal mit der
mehrbetrag für den mürbeteig verwenden
nicht 100 gramm puderzucker 200 gramm
kalte butter eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt den abrieb einer
unbehandelten limette ein eigelb und 300
gramm mehl beim möglich ist einfach nur
ganz wichtig dass die zutaten
wirklichkeit sind also kalte butter
nehmen und kaltes eigelb nehmen ich
nehme mit puderzucker
da der puderzucker ja schon ganz fein
ist dann muss ich das nicht auslösen
und ich kann den mürbeteig dann einfach
ein bisschen schneller weiter
verarbeiten
also wenn ich denn jetzt zubereite mit
normalem zucker hat sich immer
mindestens eine stunde im kühlschrank
damit sich der zucker eben auch lösen
kann und so brauche etwa 29 minuten
der kommerzielle dazu
ein extrakt knapp so ein kleines
bisschen dann auch gerne schon das
eigelb das eiweiß nimmt man bei
mürbeteig nicht da das eiweiß den teig
einfach fest macht und ich möchte keinen
festen teig sondern einen schönen mögen
teig der eben nicht hart wird
dann noch ein bisschen limiten abrieb
und dachte ich immer darauf dass sie
unbehandelt ist und dass eben auch drauf
steht zum verzehr geeignet also schale
zum verzehr geeignet dann könnte sie
wirklich ganz unbedenklich benutzen
jetzt noch das mehl dazu kurz ein kneten
und den teig wirklich nicht zu lange
verarbeiten damit er eben nicht warm
wird
schluss braucht er mir beteiligt wenn
man ihnen nicht mit der küchenmaschine
zubereitet einfach noch ein bisschen die
hand wärme damit das schön zusammen
kommt also auf die arbeitsplatte lebens
normalerweise mache ich ja noch gern mit
der küchenmaschine entweder mit dem
flach hörer oder einfach direkt mit
einem mixer mit mixa dann kommt da auch
ganz schnell zu einem schönen tag
zusammen und soll jetzt einfach noch
kurz mit den händen zusammen kneten
damit sich einfach noch die letzten
butter stückchen lösen
dass der teig schön geschmeidig und dann
drücke ich hier immer gerne ein bisschen
flach in so einem teller damit einfach
schneller abkühlt dann kommt der deckel
drauf
und da kommt in den kühlschrank und dann
kann ich ihnen gleich schon aufräumen
dieser teig schön kalt und ich habe
nochmal kurz durchgeknetet jetzt nur ein
bisschen mehr nehmen und dann rund
auswahl auf etwa 3 bis 4 millimeter
stärke einfach etwas größer als eine tat
form die er verwendet
dann eure tat formen mit etwas back
translations
dann einmal kontrollieren was er nicht
klebt mache ich mal gerne mit einer
langen palette und jetzt am besten auf
den ausbau starb auf rollen oder mit
beiden hinten ganz vorsichtig darüber
läge nicht wenn der reis ist es nicht
schlimm
das kann man gleich wieder flicken aber
so dann bevor die rennen darunter
krachen schön anpassen und mit einer
palette die ränder wegstreichen
und damit der mürbeteig geht es beim
backen schönen seine form behält werde
ich ihn jetzt nochmal einfrieren manche
banken oft blind das heißt da wird dann
backpapier draufgelegt und hülsenfrüchte
bohnen zum beispiel oder linsen zum
beschweren damit der teig beim backen
einfach nicht aufgeht ich war das jetzt
einfach ganz kurz einfrieren ich finde
das ist die einfachste methode und falls
er doch ein bisschen beim backen
hochklettert drücke ich ihn einfach
wieder flach und jetzt ganz vorsichtig
aber denn ich habe hier die tat vor mit
hebel boten damit später nach dem backen
die pi oder die torte ganz einfach
wieder rausgeht 15 minuten einfrieren
und dann kommt da in den backen der teig
schön gefroren und jetzt kommt den
backofen wird vorgebacken und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
füllung machen
für die füllung verwende ich 400 gramm
gesüßte kondensmilch daher brauche ich
ja auch keinen zucker 400 gramm
kokosmilch dies nicht gesucht den saft
von zwei limetten sechs eigelbe und 200
gramm erdbeeren die s-bahn habe ich
jetzt auftauen lassen ich habe
gefragtere genommen weil die einfach
super aromatisch sind die werden hier
immer komplett erntereif direkt
eingefroren
daher nehme ich dir ganz gerne jetzt
kurz berühren
ihr könnt jetzt die erdbeeren so lassen
oder noch ein bisschen einkochen
ich finde der geschmack intensiviert
sich dadurch weil einfach das wasser
verdunstet daher mache ich das jetzt
hier kurz einfach in den topf füllen und
dann etwa auf die hälfte reduzieren
dann müsst ihr aufpassen dass es am
topfboden nicht anklebt also nur kurz
aufkochen lassen und dann die zur
unterstellen immer schön rühren und dann
geht s wasser raus verdunstet und ich
habe einfach schönes etwas curry
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so weiter geht es mit der creme während
das hier ein koch totally verwendest du
heute keine berlin
doch wann exakt nehmen wir auch noch mit
auf die liste zu treffen und hier kann
ich jetzt schon mal die übrigen zutaten
verrühren
erst mal die eigelbe ein bisschen cremig
rühren mit vanille extrakt man wie
konnte ich die vanille los und man ihn
jetzt auch echt ein guter partner für
erdbeere
ich bin die aromen die passen einfach
perfekt zueinander vergessen
[Applaus]
ab und zu auch die erst anrücken
damit der boden hier nicht antreten
wer vom jetzige süße von werden
das wird wie so eine abschieds kate aber
ohne schießen denn ich habe keine frisch
käse und keinen quark und benutzt jetzt
einfach diese kondensmilch die macht
ganz auch super schön cremig wo weil die
eben schon gesucht ist brauche ich
wirklich keinen zucker dazu dann kommt
hier noch die kokosmilch rein da ist es
wichtig dass die nicht gelöst ist
ansonsten ist zu heftig und natürlich
noch limettensaft
[Applaus]
kurz berühren
mit sich auch warum ich 6 1 gebraucht
die macht es nämlich recht flüssig und
ich brauche die eigene war einfach zum
binden damit zu leben auch festwirt
sowohl nach dem erdbeben kurz coco und
die sind jetzt schon recht gut also ihr
seht auch super dann die probleme werden
immer kleiner weil einfach die masse
viel dichter wird und dickflüssiger und
ich glaube ich kann das jetzt hier sogar
schon ausschalten kurz abkühlen lassen
und warte einfach auf die fei kraft
[Applaus]
dabei kam es auf dem open
jetzt drücke ich ihnen ganz vorsichtig
noch mal ein bisschen flach er ist aber
nicht wirklich hoch gegangen
der rand ist auch superschön und jetzt
lasse ich den ganz kurz abgehört las
auch das etwa perry kurz abkühlen dafür
habe ich jetzt kurzum gefüllten
kühlschrank gestellt und dann geht sie
in fünf minuten mitarbeiter der möglich
ist abgekühlt und auch das etwas
abgekühlt hier ruhig sitzt direkt in die
masse mit ein
und jetzt kann die maße direkt auf den
mürbeteig gegossen werden
und die ist wirklich süß genug also da
braucht man nicht nach süßen vorsichtig
verteilen so folgenreich sitzt nicht so
den rest in fülle ich einfach irgendwo
rein und wachsen auch mit mit nicht
weggeschmissen und jetzt einfach bei
niedrigere temperatur im backofen weiter
backen und wenn er fertig ist er wackelt
dann noch in der mitte ein bisschen habe
ich nehme dann auf jeden fall raus
lassen abkühlen danach kommt doch für
eine stunde in den kühlschrank das ganz
wichtig damit er schön schnittfest wird
und dann können wir schon sagen
[Applaus]
der kuchen ist jetzt schön kalt ich habe
jetzt bereits für die deko 20 gramm
kokosraspeln und 20 gramm koks chips in
eine beschichtete pfanne gelegt und
einfach den herd auch mittlere stufe
so können sie bislang größten und das
aroma wird intensiver und die farbe wird
ein bisschen schöner zum servieren habe
ich jetzt hier noch sahne 200 gramm
da kommt etwas seiner partei vanille
extrakten puderzucker dazu und ich kann
die sahne steif schlagen
[Applaus]
und der einfach die sahne die muss ganz
so arg steif geschlagen sein ist schön
wenn es so ein bisschen lockerer ist die
kommt jetzt hier oben drauf das macht
sie aber am besten kurz vor dem verzehr
ihr könnt auch einfach jedem auf den
tellern bist du was geben darf ein paar
erdbeeren mit grünen entweder halbieren
oder vierteln darüber geben und dann
noch mit dem kokosraspeln und den kokons
chips festigen
[Applaus]
gibt man die tat lässt sich ja echt du
musst dich aus und bin verschließung die
tat lässt sich super einfach
herausnehmen
ich lieb' heben wurden hebe wurden dort
von den boden lösen haben auch noch ab
damit ich auf dem tat boden nicht
schneide man einfach mit einer palette
drunter und das geht echt super
verstehen was mit beim gewünscht ja wohl
ein messer und dann darfst du probieren
also wie gesagt könnt ihr einfach die
sahne direkt auf den teller mit geben
oder so anrichten ich finde so halt echt
super schön dass fragen ja wohl viel
prüfe ich sagen ja das falsch
geschrieben auch er weil die wissen
immer im gemeistert aber es gibt immer
ihren kommentaren jemand der schreibt du
hast tat geschrieben trotte aber tat ist
wichtig ein name ja noch eine gabel
das ist übrigens noch unser baustellen
werkzeug also bestellt
ich probiere schokolade das ist kein
schaden ich weiß was du raus schmeckt
ist das aber keine schokolade und
kokosnuss kokosmilch und der schmeckt
noch wirklich fröhlich schokolade
ich bin dir schmeckt nach einer
verengung raffaello mit erdbeere
so hat doch so schön leicht gehabt
merke ich wie gesagt gut durchgeführte
reserviert damit sie schön fest ist man
sieht auch hier ist echt super schmidt
fest und falls ihr das rezept nach
machen möchtet dann schaut auf settings
- blog.de vorbei
da steht alles noch mal ganz genau statt
erdbeeren könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
himbeeren nehmen dann sieht die farbe
auch ein bisschen schöner auswendig mal
erdbeeren sind halt immer beim kochen
und backen ein bisschen braun und
himbeeren die sind eher so king
damit heben wir das auch super lecker
und himbeeren sind ehrlich und dann wird
die tat auch nicht so süß
also viel spaß noch nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal hammer von jungs mit ja
[Musik]